what is going on everybody and welcome
back to another python and robotics
tutorial video in the last video we got
our robot car to turn left and turn
right
and in this video what we want to do is
we want to program it to pivot left and
right because then the turn it would
have to gain forward ground whereas in a
pivot it would just spin in place so uh
let's go ahead and sudo nano robot2.pi
and here's our file let's go down to the
very bottom we don't need it to turn
right anymore and now let's go ahead and
define
a pivot
underscore left time frame colon one two
three four
in it
and now we're ready to go so now to
pivot left
what we would need is since forward is
in the direction of you know going right
on screen
to pivot left the wheels closest to
the screen
would need to move
forward
whereas
the wheels in the back would need to
move
backwards and that would help it spin in
the left direction or maybe the better
word to be would be pivot or turn
counterclockwise
so to do that to make that happen what
we want to do is
we would want to use
7 as true so gpio.output
7
true
and
then we're going to need 11 to be false
so gpio.output
11
false
and then 13 should be true
true
and then 15
should be
false
now that ought to give us a pivot left
let's check it pivot left
for one second x yes save
and up to suit a python robot two dot pi
enter
and we forgot our cleanup as usual
good stuff how come nobody warned me
about this
now let's go down to the bottom
and
first of all we want to do
time.sleep for time frame and then
gpio.com clean up clean it
clean up
yes and now we're going to run it once
just to clear everything for myself and
put the battery back
and let's run it again
okay so that worked out so that would
make it pivot left now the last thing
that we really want to do is pivot right
and that should do for all of our
commands or at least you know
not commands i suppose i guess commands
yeah as far as you know what we want
this robot to be able to do so now
define
pivot right
time frame
as usual we need the initialize
and now we want to begin so what's going
to change well basically
i know this got us last time
so i hope it doesn't get me again but we
should just have to flip everything
i think we'll get away with flipping
everything this time so gpio.output
seven
false
gpio to output
11 true
gpio output
13 false
gpa output
15
true
now don't forget to sleep
time dot sleep for the time frame
and gpio dot clean up
now
we want to
pivot underscore right for the time
frame of one
save yep same file
let's do the python robot tweet up hi
run it
and shone off so the wheels closest to
us spun backwards whereas the ones
furthest from us spun forwards thus
making us turn in a clockwise
rotation or pivot right
so that's it for that now what do we
want to do well
now that we've done that we want some
way to be able to control
our uh car so you don't want to have to
like pre-program the car now there's a
few ways that you can do this either you
can allow the robot to accept controls
from you the user or you can make the
robot somewhat autonomous now the
problem right now with our little car is
we don't have any sort of real sensor to
sense when anything is happening so we
can't really make it autonomous just yet
so first we want to make it controllable
and even if you made it autonomous you
want you would want to kind of
eventually have some sort of control to
it
as a sort of fail-safe if anything
so what we're going to be doing in the
next video is actually working with some
input that we can give
to this robot to use our functions
however we see fit that way we don't
have to pre-program anything
so that's what you have to look forward
to hopefully you guys are enjoying if
you have any questions or comments feel
free to leave them below as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until the
next video